Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we’re going to talk about the material
point method.
This method uses both grids and particles
to simulate the movement of snow, dripping
honey, interactions of granular solids and
a lot of other really cool phenomena on our
computers.
This can be used, for instance, in the movie
industry to simulate what a city would look
like if it were flooded.
However, it has its own limitations, which
you will hear more about in a moment.
This paper showcases really cool improvements
to this technique, for instance, it enables
to run these simulations twice as fast, and
can simulate new phenomena that were previously
not supported by the material point method.
One is the simulation of complex thin boundaries
that enables us to cut things, so in this
video, expect lots of virtual characters to
get dismembered.
I think this might be the only channel on
YouTube where we can say this celebrate it
as an amazing scientific discovery.
And the other key improvement of this paper
is introducing two-way coupling, which means
the example that you see here as the water
changes the movement of the wheel, but the
wheel also changes with the movement of the
water.
It is also demonstrated quite aptly here by
this elastoplastic jello scene, in which we
can throw in a bunch of blocks of different
densities, and it is simulated beautifully
here how they sink into the jello deeper and
deeper as a result.
Here, you see a real robot running around
in a granular medium, and here, we have a
simulation of the same phenomenon and can
marvel at how close the result is to what
would happen in real life.
Another selling point of this method is that
this is easy to implement, which is demonstrated
here, and what you see here is the essence
of this algorithm implemented in 88 lines
of code.
Wow!
Now, these methods still take a while as there
is a lot of deformations and movement to compute
and we can only advance time in very small
steps, and as a result, the speed of such
simulations is still measured in not frames
per second, but in seconds per frame.
These are the kinds of simulations that we
like to leave on the machine overnight.
If you want to see something that is done
with a remarkable amount of love and care,
please read this paper.
And I don’t know if you have heard about
this framework called Taichi.
This contains implementations for many amazing
papers in computer graphics.
Lots of paper implementations on animation,
light transport simulations, you name it,
a total of more than 40 papers are implemented
here.
And I was thinking, this is really amazing,
“I wonder which group made this”, then
I noticed it was all written by one person.
And that person is Yuanming Hu, the scientist
who is the lead author of this paper.
This is insanity.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!